all right let's get to hey tree at male
it is that time of the week hatred mail
when a professional voice-over artist as
interpretive readings of the hatred mail
that I get a quick reminder about hey
trio mail first because we don't care
about liberal cucks so much that we
spend our time writing to them Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom so I I think that this week's
hatred mail I think it's racist right I
mean let's take a look at it just came
across this channel your channel is
nothing but liberal propaganda appealing
to uneducated [ __ ] idiots
I'm sure anyone who has trumped
arrangements in Rome and can't deal with
the real world loves this channel if
anyone wants a good laugh stop by E and
listen to this complete idiot and read
the comments your comedy what happened
to o bunga's redline so this entire a
bunga bunga and oh bombuh
are those racist terms about Barack
Obama my impression is that they are
that they are sort of ridiculing or
referencing what what are sort of like
stereotypical quote backwards sounding
African words or names or something like
that is oh bombuh may be related to
bumbling like a bumbling fool I don't
know it doesn't sound great to me though
but once again I I think that it's
important to remember that even when
hatreds
engage with our content when hatreds
show up on my youtube channel and
downvote
my videos or leave a negative comment
it's still engagement it still helps us
on the YouTube algorithm when you hate
listen to my podcast it's still good for
me it's still a listen that I can then
go to an advertiser and say this is the
number we have and if five or 10 percent
of those are hatreds then that's five or
10 percent more that we can charge for
advertising just remember that folks the
best way to fight patriotism
correctly is to become a member on my
website join pakman.com using the coupon
code hey tree at 40 h80 our iot 4-0 you
save 40% off of your membership and the
hey tree it's burst into flames
spontaneously because their attempt to
sabotage or sabotage the show
to quote William Shatner it's been a
while since I said that don't work and
that is a really great thing for
independent progressive media